the Joe Rogan experience this means as
much to us as anybody except for you
well it's nice to see it this is my this
is my happy place this is my safe place
yeah I got to travel across the country
to be safe but it's a it's certainly a
pleasure to be here again enjoy always
have to thank you I listen more I thank
you too I was texting Whitney today I
said you're a hero
you're a legitimate hero for people
don't know what this is all about I'll
give everybody the backstory Phil used
to work at Marineland he was an orca
trainer and he also trained a walrus
named smoochy smoochy is still allegedly
in captivity at Marineland all those no
photographic evidence but you're pretty
sure she's still there I was told that
she is still there and she's in good
shape and I'm hanging on to that since
you came on the podcast the first time
which was how many years ago No so six
years ago a thousand thirteen so he's
been living this lawsuit life for six
years trapped in a lawsuit with a
gigantic corporation with incredible
amounts of money that's been trying to
crush him and they've made up stuff well
tell me what's what's happened give give
me your your perspective on how it all
went back in 2012 I made I was forced to
make a very difficult decision I elected
to speak out against the conditions of
which marine lands animals were living
in I did so knowing the risks knowing
that marine life was a litigious company
but I did so on account to the fact that
the animals were suffering incredibly
before quitting I had an agreement with
marine land that look I'm leaving this
is long before I'd spoke out I'd spoken
out I'm leaving but you know we have to
establish that I can maintain this
relationship with the walrus because I
am printed on her it's important to
stress that that she thinks I'm her mom
as she was a baby she was a baby when
she came in so she was wild caught and
you can imagine probably witnessed her
mother get slaughtered that's the that's
the method of collecting babies by the
by the captors in Russia
and so she comes in traumatic at the age
of we estimate about 18 months of age
which is pretty old in fact for in our
experience at marine lands experience of
acquiring these wild-caught baby
walruses and through a sort of traumatic
experience with her that I was there
with her this anomalous thing happened
where her brain circuitry opened up and
much like in the wild where in the case
of herd animals the babies become
familiar with the mother's sounds and
look everything all the senses are acute
they're aware of who they of where they
are so that they can you know find each
other amidst these thousands of animals
well this happened to her so the brain
circuitry opens suddenly I'm imprinted
on her I wasn't prepared to leave marine
land unless it was of the understanding
that I can continue to help her because
historically my relationship with her
you know had everything to do with her
health and well-being I quit with the
understanding with marine land this was
to be the case I'd been gone for a month
I come back unannounced they don't want
to let me in they're hiding something I
get in I see her she's in terrible shape
I snap a few photos I leave now amidst
this you see terrible shape what do you
mean she was emaciated she was bone dry
she hadn't eaten in my having been gone
a month was the longest she and I have
ever actually been physically apart I'd
been trying to wean my presence off of
her so that other trainers who would be
able to maintain a healthy you know
healthy diet for healthy life she was
emaciated because she wasn't eating
cause of stress I wasn't there for that
month I can't say but she was certainly
not eating she was super skinny they had
her of course on a bunch of drugs which
include psychotics valium
antidepressants I when I saw her my jaw
hit the floor it's important to note
that during this some newspapers had
been calling they wanted to know why I
quit if we back up a little bit it
should be noted that in 2007 my
relationship with smooshy sort of took
off in the early sort of internet viral
days and whatnot we made front page of
like CNN and Jimmy Kimmel did a piece
and
so there was sort of that backstory of
the you know I guess you would call it a
fluff celebrity type thing but
nonetheless my having left started
people start to ask questions I started
feeling calls from this newspaper who's
looking was keen on doing an
investigation of Marineland so I wasn't
gonna participate I had no interest
again stressing marine lands litigious
history and also look I've got this
relationship with a walrus that I I sort
of have to maintain I have to really
have to keep this relationship with
marina and healthy enough so once I'd
realized they weren't holding on to that
end of the bargain you know the panic
sets in I'm a first-time mom it should
be stressed so I I basically called the
newspapers and I said you put my face my
name and it doesn't matter you just
print it let's go let's let's get the
story out story gets out well Marineland
as expected starts their lawsuits they'd
it's like it's almost like a scorched
earth they take a scorched earth sort of
method and this was when the original
owner was alive yes is no longer alive
he died he died last year in in June in
fact so years into this litigation so
they sued me they sued me for a million
five they sued my girlfriend they sued
other activists they sued newspapers
they they're suing everybody the mistake
they made is in all of their absurd
allegations that they've yet six and a
half years into into litigation yet to
prove any of it they cannot it's never
gonna happen it doesn't exist it's a
fictitious lawsuit it's full of lies and
[ __ ] bottom line the mistake they
made as they sued me for plotting to
steal smooshy that's where the headlines
take off and they also called me the
Kanye West of animal training yeah I got
your attention on the internet that's
how you got my sweet I said the kanye
west part didn't get right well no you
said they called you the tweet was I
said Joe you just say when I'll book a
flight to come to LA I sent you the link
to the to the story the headline was
kanye west of animal training being sued
for plotting to steal of walrus you
wrote they called you though what
and then you slip the DMS and said dude
if you're ever in LA I said you just say
when what
[Applause]